a team of engineering students at the
University of California San Diego have
entered themselves into the Google Lunar
X prime end its space program with a
proposal that's considered unusual for
science but typical for San Diego
college students they want to make beer
and space from a scientific I know from
a scientific standpoint their goal is to
study the effects on the yeast which
could lead to a better understanding of
how to make other foods in space however
it's possible at this plant to binge
drink on the moon could just be the
latest attempt by the Russians to
undermine us with a space contest they
could actually win for once yeah that's
right we burn Russia that was for Lika
the space so this idea becomes a reality
what's the transmission NASA might
receive from a team of space drunks Jeff
Ross one small step for sobriety 11 more
steps to go all right points very good
very very good Mike Lawrence
this is ground control I made your bomb
tomorrow houston we have a drinking
problem
[Applause]